das projekt eines us forschungsteams
klingt wie science-fiction tor
demnach könnten schon bald nano roboter
ins menschliche gehirn geschleust werden
die dessen signale in echtzeit mit einer
internet cloud verbinden so könnten wir
uns nicht nur per gedankenkraft im
internet bewegen sondern auch jede
person auf dieser welt mit zu unseren
ganz persönlichen erinnerungen nehmen
bot tricks um science fiction die gibt's
täglich faszinierendes seines videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst er
nichts herzlich willkommen als diese
vision einmal zur realität wird ändert
sich unser leben von jetzt auf gleich
denn dann wären wir in der lage per
gedankenkraft im internet zu surfen aber
nicht nur das uns stünde das gesamte
wissen der menschheit zu jedem zeitpunkt
unbegrenzt zur verfügung egal ob es um
das paarungsverhalten der rothirsche
geht oder aber um das erste bild eines
schwarzen lochs doch nicht nur das auch
unseren ganz persönlichen erinnerungen
und gefühle die wir beispielsweise mit
einem ganz besonderen urlaub verbinden
könnten wir dann eins zu eins mit
anderen menschen teilen diese könnten
dann beispielsweise nachempfinden wie
sich der sieger des marathonlaufes
gefühlt hat oder aber was der
us-präsident kurz vor dem einschlafen
denkt glaubt man dem us
neurowissenschaftler nur martins wird
genau das schon in naher zukunft möglich
sein in seiner aktuellen studie ist die
rede von nano roboter die in den
kommenden 20 bis 30 jahren ins
menschliche gehirn geschleust werden
könnten und unser denkorgan somit einer
internet cloud verbinden dazu robert
freitags der an der studie beteiligt war
diese geräte würden durch die
menschlichen gefäße wandern die
blut-hirn-schranke überqueren und sich
präzise zwischen oder sogar innerhalb
von gesund sehen selbst positionieren
sie würden dann fundierte informationen
drahtlos zu und von einem
cloud-basierten supercomputer netzwerk
übertragen um in echtzeit den zustand
des gehirns zur überwachung von daten zu
extrahieren
ein supercomputer würde dann die
unzähligen signale des menschlichen
gehirns speichern und in einem
zusammenhang bringen so würde es möglich
werden diese riesigen datenmengen auch
zu einem späteren zeitpunkt noch einmal
abzurufen eine gigantische datenbank
würde entstehen die das gesamte wissen
der menschheit enthält und auf die jede
person zu jederzeit zugreifen könnte
laut experten würde dies nicht nur das
wissen sondern auch die intelligenz und
die lern kapazitäten der menschen extrem
verbessern
doch nicht nur dass solch ein globales
super brain das individuelle gehirne und
künstliche intelligenz verbindet könnte
auch kollektives denken möglich machen
die gedanken und denkt kraft vieler
menschen und maschinen könnten also in
echtzeit genutzt werden was der studie
zufolge sogar die demokratie
revolutionieren könnte laut des
forschungsteams würde dies aber noch
weitere bislang ungeahnte möglichkeiten
zu lassen beispielsweise könnte dieses
projekt die erde zu einem toleranteren
und empathischen ort machen so die
fachleute
denn die nano roboter würden dafür
sorgen dass wir die gefühle anderer
menschen viel besser nachvollziehen
können
dafür könnte eine art des sozialen
netzwerkes geschaffen werden und das so
genannte transparency boeing die es
möglich machen dazu heißt es in der
studie
durch die es könnten einzelpersonen
episodische abschnitte des lebens
anderer freiwilliger teilnehmer lokal
oder weit entfernt erleben auf diese
weise können hoffentlich verständnis und
toleranz unter allen menschlichen
lebewesen verbessert werden ihre idee
wollen die autoren mit magneto
elektrischen nanopartikeln umsetzen und
so die kommunikation zwischen den
neuronen und der cloud ermöglichen dazu
der forscher nur martins diese
nanopartikel wurde bereits in lebenden
mäusen getestet um externe magnetfelder
mit neuronalen elektr
den feldern zu koppeln das heißt dass
die magnetischen signale erfasst und
lokal verstärkt werden und so
elektrische aktivität von neuronen zu
ändern
das könnte auch in puncto nieren von
neuronen und nano robotern erzeugte
elektrische signale könnte über magneto
elektrische nanopartikeln verstärkt
werden damit sie außerhalb des schädels
nachgewiesen werden können im großen und
ganzen klingt das forschungsteam
optimistisch solch ein projekt schon in
naher zukunft umzusetzen schon in 20 bis
30 jahren sollte dies nach angaben der
fachleute möglich sein doch klar ist
auch dass vorher noch viele
herausforderungen anstehen zunächst
müssten nano-partikel entwickelt werden
die für diese technologie genutzt werden
könnten doch wie sollen diese dann ins
menschliche gehirn geschleust werden
ohne dabei schaden anzurichten
zudem stehen wir vor einer menge
ungeklärter fragen könnte man sicher
sein
das sehr private erinnerungen unter
diesen umständen auch privat bleiben
werden sie dennoch abgespeichert und
welche folgen hätte ein möglicher hacker
angriff auf die systeme könnten
kriminelle also zugriff auf unsere
gedanken haben und seit gehirn hecken
und sogar manipulieren dafür hier
klicken und das video anschauen und
natürlich doktor watson abonnieren bis
dann bleib dran